I'm in the middle of London on Regent
Street in case you couldn't tell with
all those red buses going by we want to
talk about something a little bit
Olympics we're going to talk to you
about flags
there's loads of flags up the street
there but we want to talk about one in
particular it's one you don't often see
at the games because well this country's
never actually won a medal but their
flag very mathematical we got chatting
about countries and their flags and
things and I thought well what sort of
maths could we do with that and we could
look at the symmetry of flags and which
has the most symmetrical flag then I
thought no I know what the most
mathematical flag is and this is amazing
so the pole I reckon has the most
mathematical flag the country of Nepal
because the mathematical construction
for the flag is actually written into
their constitution and I've got it here
this is article 5 of the Nepal
Constitution where it describes how to
construct the nations flag so I read it
you schedule one relating to article 5
national flag a method of making the
shape inside the border
one on the lower portion of a crimson
cloth draw a line a B of the required
length from left to right to from a draw
a line AC perpendicular to a be making a
C equal to a B plus one third a B from
AC mark of D making a line ad equal to
line a B join BD from BD mark off e
making be e equal to a B for touching e
draw a line F G starting from the point
F on line AC parallel to a B to the
right hand side mark off F G equal to a
B 5 join CG I believe it is the only
flag for a country certainly that isn't
a square or a rectangle makes it very
unusual but Nepal are bucking the trend
they're sticking with it this is their
flagging
sticking with it from a bee Markov aah
making a H equal to one-fourth of line a
B and starting from H draw a line H I
parallel to line AC touching line CG at
point I if it was on cloth we could just
like fold it in half and mark it C so
maybe I'll do that with I want to draw
half this distance bisect CF at J and
draw a line
JK parallel to a be touching CG at point
K is not necessary to have to measure
with your ruler you can follow these
instructions without any measuring at
all it's telling you to divide things by
half and quarters and thirds and using
those rules without measuring we should
be able to do this let L be the point
where lines JK + H I cut one another 9
join JG 10 let M be the point where line
JG and hate I cut one another with
Center M and with a distance shortest
from M 2 BD knockoff clanking a straight
face okay with Center M and with a
distance shortest from M 2 BD Markoff n
to the lower portion of line hate i
touching m and starting from o a point
four on AC draw a line from left to
right parallel to a be with center l and
radius L n draw a semicircle and on the
lower portion and let P and Q be the
points where it touches the line om
respectively with Center m and radius MQ
draw a semicircle on the lower portion
touching P and Q with Center m and
radius nm draw an arc touching pnq at R
and s join RS let t be the point where
our s and H I cut one
another 16 with center t and radius TS
draw a semicircle on the upper portion
of pnq touching it at two points this is
what mathematics was like in ancient
times and this is what it was like to
the Greeks all not Greek mathematics was
like this and written down like this
with center T and radius TM draw an arc
on the upper portion of pnq touching at
two points eight equal and similar
triangles of the moon are to be made in
the space lying inside the semicircle of
number 16 and outside the arc of number
17 of this schedule I made that bit up I
cheated a little bit just let see method
of making the Sun bisects line a F at
you and draw a line UV parallel to line
a be touching line B e @v I'm gone blind
ah si it's all swimming now okay with
Center W the point where H I and UV cut
one another and radius MN draw a circle
got two W there isn't any X's and Zed so
yes we nearly that it took that many
letters though it took nearly the whole
alphabet just be glad there aren't 27
steps what we would have done that with
Center W and radius Ln draw a circle 12
equal and similar triangles of the Sun
are to be made in the space enclosed by
the circles our number 20 and of number
21 and with the two apex of two
triangles touching line H I D method of
making the border the width of the
border will be equal to the width of TN
this will be a deep blue color and will
be provided on all sides of the flag
however on the five angles of the flag
the external angles will be equal to the
internal angles explanation the lines
HIRS fe e DJ g oq j k and UV are
imaginary
similarly the external internal circles
of the Sun and the other arcs except the
crescent moon are also imagining these
are not shown on the flag and it's as
easy as it sounds
you